I'm Mark hbin let's answer some
questions from the internet this is
Mogul
[Music]
support at Young entrep Hub what will be
your best advice to those who are
thinking of leaving their full-time jobs
to become a full-time entrepreneur save
your money first don't just leave unless
you know what the hell you're doing we
hear all these stories about all these
people who quit their job started a
company and made all this money what you
don't hear are the stories of the people
who quit their job starting a company
and failed miserably and are now working
at a job they hate before you quit be
prepared know what you're doing save
your money have at least 6 months to
live off if you can and then maybe
you're ready to start your business
Allen Bramley question do billionaires
create jobs the answer is no
entrepreneurs create jobs I'm an
entrepreneur and I do my best to create
jobs but the reality is in order to
become a billionaire the one thing you
have to have is luck any billionaire who
tells you they could just do it
again no you have to be lucky maybe you
have a rich parent question I get asked
a lot is should billionaires pay more in
taxes yeah we should pay more in
taxes I would not be in this position
without this country because nothing
happens that's great whether it's Health
Care teachers roads you name it without
people paying their taxes it may be
painful when you write that big check
but just think about how you got there
one of the most patriotic things that
you can do when you're wealthy is pay
your taxes at jcba YC you
have 6 months to make as much money as
possible all you have to start with is a
phone and $500 in cash what are you
doing jcba ayc that is the best question
I have ever been asked in my entire
adult life I am really really really
good at sales I'm going to find a sales
job because I already know that that if
I'm on to my last $500 and all I have is
a phone I am going to get that job and
I'm going to learn more about that
industry than anybody on the planet and
I'm going to set a commission as high as
I possibly can and 3 months in when I've
demonstrated that I am the best
salesperson in the history of that
company I'm going to walk into my boss's
office and I'm going to tell him or her
you're either going to pay me this
amount of money to keep me or I'm going
to start my own business selling this
stuff that is exactly what I would do
everything always goes back to sales no
matter what an jan1 if you buy shares of
a sports team is it a gamble or an
investment it's a gamble because you're
a minority shareholder you have no
rights at Mike
25748 92x question is the customer
always right no the customer is rarely
right that doesn't mean you don't have
to keep them happy do customers make
choices of course they make choices
we're all customers we know how we
choose what we buy and what we don't buy
but the reality is you don't spend a
minute of your day wondering what the
next product should be at 7-Eleven do
you the customer is not the one who
comes up with the ideas it's the
entrepreneur that comes up with the
ideas Ed jamus wants to know what are
some great businesses that people don't
realize I'm going to tell you a couple
easy off the top of my head that if I
wanted to start a company I would
seriously look at this number one Alexa
Alexa has so many capabilities and so
many people have them but they have no
idea how to use any the programming
scripting capabilities of Alexa you can
go and start a business where you could
go to your neighbors to car dealerships
to businesses and show them for 50 bucks
an hour or more how to use their Alexa
in their homes to save energy to save
time in their businesses and two that
leads to the same thing happening with
large language models like chat GPT
there's new features coming out in chat
GPT and its competitors every single
month so if you just get involved and
stay ahead you're going to be the person
in demand and selling your services on
how to prompt chat GPT to help a
business or even to tutor kids on how to
best use it for school at cinemod is
back if you could change one thing about
the sports industry college or Pro what
would you change dumb question I changed
the officiating at Ash Crypt you think
crypto is dead yes or no no hell no but
I do think crypto has some problems
number one most people when they think
crypto they think speculation that's not
what crypto is really about number two
CP crypto is really about creating new
applications that make things better and
easier what crypto is missing is that
one application that Grandma really
wants to use think back to the iPhone it
came out in 2007 but it wasn't until the
best apps like Instagram and Snapchat
and Facebook went mobile that the App
Store and the iPhone really took off
crypto is still waiting for its
Instagram moment it won't be all that
much longer where we'll be able to use
an nft as a ticket once the ticket is
resold we don't make a a penny the
scalpers make all the money if that
ticket was an nft and it will be in the
future every time it's resold the
original ticket holder can make some
money the team can make some money you
can't do that with physical tickets you
can't do that with traditional digital
transfer you can do that when you turn
it into crypto or an nft when that
happens crypto go up at blessing
91077 312 why do most businesses
fail
number one sales no business has ever
succeeded without sales period end of
story number two preparation when you go
to start a business have you done all
the homework to know about your industry
your competition your products the
profitability your customer base their
demographics you need to know these
things three effort it is not easy
starting and running a business it's
hard if it was easy everybody would do
it and four brains you got to be smart
you got to learn this stuff you got to
put in the effort you have to be curious
in order to be successful at business
you do these four things blessing and
you'll be okay company doesn't do them
they're in deep trouble at ghost
93X everybody losing money in nfts why
are you still here LOL I got a handy
dandy graph this is the nft market and
this is the volume of sales basically it
sucks you know how many other Industries
have sucked there was a time after the
Internet stock market crashed where
Amazon was selling for $5 a share
Microsoft was selling for hundredth of
what they sell right now if you ever
been in the trading card industry that
Mickey manle card that you know Steph
Curry card goes up goes down go up go
down the same thing is happening to nfts
now there are some people that would
tell you that this is the best time if
you're an nft collector to buy an nft
I'm not going to tell you what you
should or shouldn't do other than to say
with nfts the best time to buy is when
you're a collector and you love the nft
don't buy to speculate I'm gonna say it
to you for the people in the back
[Music]
don't
speculate yeah you know what happens to
speculators they get their ass handed to
them I can stare at my Mutant Punk all
day long cuz I collected it I'm not
paying attention to all the things that
happen on a day-to-day basis and you
shouldn't either because someday we're
going to turn around and you know what
you're going to say to yourself you're
going to say to
yourself
I should have bought those damn nfts
when they were next to nothing at Tamar
shahan what's something you wish your
younger self knew before starting a
business I wish I would have known to
respect the people around me and to be
nice to the people around me that worked
for me more because it's stressful
starting a business and I think too
often I took that stress out on the
people around me and that was a mistake
at earnest earnest 4 name image likeness
you get paid for that dear God what is
wrong with the NCAA Ernest you just
busted your ass asked for the first 17
18 years of your life to be great at
something you get recruited by a school
and somebody there wants to pay you for
your name image and likeness now if that
same kid was a violinist and they wanted
to pay them to do an ad for violins You'
be like yeah when an athlete makes it to
the top at their level and Advertiser a
sponsor wants to pay them yeah let them
earn the rewards of their efforts
earnest n iil hell yeah at becoming a
mirror who is the best shark on Shark
Tank and why is it Mark cubin I'm the
best shark on Shark Tank cuz I've been
there I've been broke I've been fired
started a business with nothing built a
business into something so when you're
on that carpet pitching to us not only
am I thinking to myself will I invest
but I'm also trying to come up with a
way that I can help that entrepreneur
because I know the challenge the pain
the anxiety of running a business and if
I can make your life a little bit easier
with a good ide idea that's what I'm
going to do at Turner orinks what is a
business buzzword that annoys you the
most I'll go first disruptor cohort
there's no reason to ever use the word
cohort when you can use the word group a
cohort is a group of people say group
you sound stupid when you use the word
cohort because you're trying to sound
smart always use the simpler word at
bash terminal can anyone explain to
layman terms what is series ABCD funding
I don't know why people apply these
letters just the chronological order in
which you raise money that's it preed
seed series a series B series C Series d
That's it it can come from anybody come
from Mom it come from Dad it can come
from your Aunt your uncle a venture
capitalist what is Venture Capital
venture capital is a vulture that sits
in an office telling you how smart they
are and how they're going to give you
money in exchange for too much of your
company to give you too little support
to end up trying to push you to do
things that you don't want to do just so
they can get their money back but other
than that I have no problem with them at
searing what is the most common mistake
you see entrepreneurs make they focus
completely on raising money the less
money you raise the better because
that's how you own more of your company
because when you raise money you have to
give away part of your company so the
biggest most important rule is
understanding that raising money is not
an accomplishment it's an obligation at
mahavir Jin what are the three daily
habits or practices that have
significantly contributed to your
success
read read read read read got to learn
two be
curious changes you got to always
be curious you got to know what's up you
got to stay on top of it three be agile
because the shit's changing because
you're learning all the new stuff that
you're curious about you always got to
be agile and be able to adapt and for
abs always be selling you got to always
be selling because that's the way
businesses work you do those things
you're going to crush it and the four
that was a bonus I said three things I
can't count at Joe bass HD what is the
difference between cost per acquisition
CPA and customer acquisition cost CAC
let's just start
with cost for acquisition this is the
amount it cost you to acquire a customer
then there is customer acquisition cost
that is your cost to acquire a customer
so the only thing missing between these
two is the equal sign between them to
tell you that they are pretty much the
exact same thing typically what happens
is people will go and advertise on
social media platform and they'll spend
$1,000 and after the week or whenever it
is till it runs out they'll look to see
how many customers that they have let's
just say they have 100 customers then
you just do the math 1,000 divided 100
gives you for all the math wizzes out
there $10 now what is that $10 that's
your customer acquisition cost or cost
for acquisition at keep on trucking 78
as a business owner when is it time to
call it quits walk away give up sell
move on cut your losses you get the idea
that decision typically is going to be
made for you you can't pay your bills
you can't pay your employees you can't
pay your bank loan and somebody's coming
in and you look Mark the game's over
it's the worst feeling ever just because
the hits the fan and things are
going wrong that's never the time you
only close up shop when you have no
choice or if someone offers you so much
money it's just like hell yes then you
look at selling them are you ready to
take another step in your life is the
most important thing to you running that
business regardless of how much it's
worth or is there so much money involved
here that you can change your life like
when I sold my first business I retired
and bought a lifetime pass in American
Airlines the most valuable asset to me
wasn't the money it was the time the
money could buy you have to make your
own decision on what's most important to
you at
g167
28893 did you ever want to give up what
did you do to get out of the funk I
remember when I started my first
business I had no sales and I remember
being terrified I mean the anxiety was
through the roof but I just you know
reminded myself why I started and
reminded myself that I made a shitty ass
employee I was never going to be good at
working for somebody else I was allow to
employee because I was a knowitall right
I I was an entrepreneur at heart and I
always thought I had a better idea I
worked for a bank I called up an
executive VP said we want to have a
happy hour where you talk about what
it's like to work at the bank I thought
that was a really cool idea and I was
taking initiative my boss brought me
into his office who the hell do you
think you are who gave you permission to
do this you know you just started here
what the I had a tear coming from I
mean I'd never felt anything like that
before and I just knew then that I was
not destined to be an employee at obial
Kenobi why the is medicine so
expensive in America this is bull yes it
is OB ra Kenobi and what I've learned in
disrupting Industries when an industry's
been doing it the same way for decades
that's one green flag for me to get in
when that same industry does everything
possible to complicate the business so
no one else can get in that's a second
green flag for me to get involved third
when it's so complicated but when you
look at it it's like this is a simple
business you know what the prescription
drug business really is somebody makes
the drugs somebody buys the drugs
someone prescribes the drugs someone
sells the drugs that is it that's the
whole prescription drug industry and so
when I saw that I'm like this shit's
going to be easy not cheap but easy to
do and so we started cost plusus
drugs.com in January of 2022 when
there's an industry that's doing it the
same way forever making things more
complicated and everybody hates them
that is the best place to start a
business so you too can dunk on whoever
you choose to dunk on so those were all
the questions for today thanks there
were some amazing questions I really
enjoyed them if I can leave you with any
words the only reason to consider being
an entrepreneur starting your own
company investing is to make your life
better just enjoy your time have fun do
your best good things will happen thanks
for watching Mogul
support